I'm spider-man and in my world more than
one where's the mat-su dog and it's a no
on the Cape I think it's cool
spider-man doesn't wear a cape hey guys
who are you I'm Gwen Stacy how many more
spider people are there and to Bob hey
fellas this could literally not get any
weirder it can get weirder spider-man
into the spider-verse new animals
talking this to mention cuz I don't want
to freak him out your universe there's
only one spider-man but there is another
universe my name is Miles Morales hey if
you're like me how I know it's
complicated
you want to know what happened to you I
can teach you to be spider-man how am I
supposed to save the world you can't
think about saving the world you have to
think about saving one person what makes
you different what makes you spider-man
I see the spark in you it's amazing
whatever you choose to do with it you'll
be great
I love you miles yeah I know dad you
gotta say I love you back dad are you
serious I want to hear it dad I love you
Oh God
thing is I'm a gentleman
you did not you could have come right in
but you had to go and sneak around time
to bring the fear back good evening New
York welcome at tonight's entertainment
the changing of the guard the night the
good old days are coming back
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new spider-man footage to break
down spider-man into the spider-verse
trailer new spider-man ps4 footage for
the upcoming DLC in the new story arc
and spider-man far from home so there is
a new round of that spider-man game
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a spider-man
related comment on the video we're
entering prime spider-man season like in
the next couple of weeks obviously
there's a bunch of other Marvel stuff
happening The Avengers 4 trailer
although Captain Marvel stuff but a
whole bunch of spider-man so just
starting with the spider-man into the
spider verse footage we get a little
more Wilson Fisk more Ultimate Goblin
and more the Prowler they seem like
they're gonna be the only real main
villains during this first film like
they're introducing the concept of the
multiverse with a couple other versions
of spider-man like spider-gwen
spider-man noir Peter porker the
40-something midlife crisis version of
spider-man played by Jake Johnson but
what I'm hoping is is because we have
all that spider gettin stuff happening
in the comics right now that they'll
find a way to get up to really crazy
multiverse stories more Lund in more
true comic-book spider-verse storyline
like we have this first film you
introduced the concept of the multiverse
other Spider Men come to help miles on
his earth the sequel should be miles
traveling the multiverse with them in a
story with even bigger scope if the
animated movies go as well as people
think that they're gonna go it seems
like the beginning of a new animated
franchise and because it's animation you
can do anything you want there are no
limitations in the audience
typically expects it to be a little bit
crazier so it doesn't have to be quite
as broad as say the live-action movies
have to be if you're not a big comic
book reader spider get in is sort of
like the big sequel storyline to the
spider verse comic book storyline where
spider-man in his counterparts from all
the alternate universes in prison more
Lund who's like the big overarching
multiverse villain that's trying to kill
them all spider Ganon is the story of
how they escaped and how things get even
worse in the multiverse and everything
starts to crumble around them so sort of
this giant battle royale across all of
time and space in the multiverse with
spider-man's specific characters you get
into the idea of the web of life and
destiny which is sort of this
overarching concept that sits on top of
the multiverse it's like this way
that literally connects all the
alternate universes swigging this
animated universe is the perfect place
to deal with stuff like that you get a
little teaser for that when you see
spider-gwen falling between universes
there's this cosmic web in the
background those strands literally
connect different universes in the
multiverse so early prediction they have
spider-man into the spider verse is this
first film relatively simple concept
they could do shattered Dimensions for
the sequel and then that third film
could be called spider gedan or at least
based on the concept of spider get in
and called something else that they want
to change the title the new Spider Man
ps4 footage is just him versus
hammerhead it's called turf wars aka the
city that never sleeps there are three
new Spider Man suits we have the spider
armor mark 1 the classic version the
spider clan suit from the manga verse
and then the comic book iron spider suit
with the classic red gold coloring I
know everybody wants to see that black
costume the symbiote we have that venom
post-credit scene with Harry Osborn it
seems like they're definitely saving
that for the sequel now there is one
more DLC pack and they sort of tell you
what it is through a couple Easter eggs
in this trailer so obviously hammerhead
is the next big film that he goes after
URI comes back and becomes a much bigger
character but you see me this big fight
with hammerhead wearing a jet pack and
notice that they slow it down quite a
bit when he flies past the frame you see
a giant S on the back and you wonder
what that is
it stands for silver main so it seems
like they're trying to imply that silver
main is the next big villain that he
faces I'll explain his comic book
storyline in a second because it does
foreshadow what they've been doing with
the kingpin going down and everybody
fighting over turf in the city the
release date for the hammerhead DLC in
all these new suits is November 20th
next week as of me posting this video
the next DLC pack after that is called
silver linings just confirming this
silver main is the next big villain they
only say that it's coming out sometime
in December but I'm just guessing that
it's going to be released sometime
around went into the spider-verse his
theatres but silver main in the comics
debuted in the 60s is sort of a follow
up mob boss villain to the kingpin
because the kingpin was a really early
spider-man villain but he got into this
really crazy mystical storyline where he
tried to de-age himself using a special
serum in a Miss
tablet forcing Curt Connors the lizard
to help him eventually it was successful
he reemerged in his late 30s his next
big storyline was going fool kingpin
trying to consolidate all of New York's
crime families before seemingly dying in
a big battle with spider-man on a
rooftop then way later during the 80s he
re-emerged and they did that cybernetic
bodies storyline if you remember that
from the animated series that happened
during the 80s when things got really
really crazy with his character but that
90's animated series did do a version of
all of his greatest hits where he tried
to d-h himself using the tablet he had a
daughter that worked with Curt Connors
that then took over his crime family
after the tablet went all wonky and D
aged him into a baby I'm trying to keep
my expectations low for the Silvermane
DLC I don't know how big it's going to
be so just don't expect them to do every
single thing from his comic book
storylines but I know you're all
wondering when we're getting footage for
spider-man far from home so I talked
about then dropping this Silvermane DLC
around the time spider-man into the
spider versus hitting theaters most
recent news about spider-man far from
home is that they will drop the teaser
trailer with spider-man into the spider
verse that his theaters December 14th so
maybe we see that teaser trailer Tuesday
December 11th a little bit earlier that
week movie studios loved that Tuesday
before big movies come out so that's
just what I'm penciling in on my
calendar right now but if I get any more
news about that I'll post it in the
comments that's also gonna be the same
week that we get the big flash arrow
Elseworlds crossover with a black
Superman and everybody's switching sides
Freaky Friday style so there's gonna be
a whole bunch of comic-book stuff
happening that week but also don't
forget Aquaman is hitting theaters the
week after that too but I'll talk about
Aquaman stuff and all my DC videos so
December will be a really big comic book
month and we'll spend the holidays
talking about the future of spider-man
in the Marvel Universe in phase 4
what'll happen is there's a couple other
Marvel videos that I'm working on I'll
try to post those as soon as possible
click here for my Stan Lee tribute and
click here for the new Avengers for
Captain Marvel prequel story thank you
so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you